[Music]
there's so many reasons why i do what i
do
i love surfing and i love helping people
i think if everybody found what they
love to do what they were designed to do
and use that gift to help others this
world would look so different
[Music]
my name is lambert lowe and i'm a surf
instructor
i was living in hawaii living the dream
teaching surfing to billionaires and
celebrities
at the end of the day something was
missing and i knew in my heart that i
needed to come back to where it all
started
i grew up in california
the ocean was where i felt the most
connected
i came back and started a non-profit
called the mix academy
[Music]
one of the things that come out of the
mix academy is this surf school
and i brought that gift of surfing here
with some of the people that need the
push up from most smiles
stand up go my current class consists of
a refugee from north korea
nathan a nine-year-old who's visually
impaired and shannon a veteran going
through alcoholism
[Music]
school of the misfits is a place where
you can belong on land everyone looks at
us a little differently but when you're
in the water the water washes all that
off
surfing like life is full of ups and
downs there's waves that are coming and
you can't stop that from coming pain is
going to come what you can't control is
yourself and how you're going to react
you can choose to paddle for it embrace
it adapt to it and enjoy the ride or
this wave is going to come and it's
going to knock you out and it's going to
wipe you out
catching a wave is a great feeling
helping others catch their first wave is
a greater feeling to watch that smile
just ear to ear and knowing that man
that's gonna change someone's life
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
women surfers have been marketed very
sexually you'd see a girl in a string
bikini or a g-string standing on a beach
but when we go out there it's totally
different we're wearing full suits and
hoods and booties and we're not trying
to be sexy we're going out there to
become stronger better more awesome
humans
big way of surfing is really ferocious
people have said that women can't surf
it
but i do
i'm bianca valenti and i'm a
professional big wave surfer in san
francisco california
11 years ago is when i first served in
san francisco i nearly drowned and that
was when i decided i wanted to put in
the time in and out of the water and
start training to prepare and ride big
waves
[Music]
the water in san francisco is really
really cold sometimes there's even ice
on the sand in the morning and when it's
super cold your hands are tingly you
have to have a really thick skin and you
have to be very driven determined and
motivated because
this is in hawaii
mavericks is a surf spot where gigantic
waves break
it's been called the mount everest of
surfing and it is located 20 minutes
south of san francisco
[Music]
an average-sized wave is three to four
feet maverick starts breaking at 15 feet
and there's been waves written in there
up to a hundred feet
people have died surfing mavericks it is
serious business it's for experts only
there's excitement there's fear
adrenaline
nervousness
happiness
it's really every emotion at once
when i hear somebody say that women are
not strong enough or good enough to surf
big lamps i just start laughing because
it makes me feel alive and i love it
it's about challenging yourself it's
about persevering and
and overcoming obstacles and so it's a
much deeper
experience for me personally and that's
why i embrace
surfing in san francisco
[Music]
[Music]
they call this stretch of the north
shore the seven mile miracle
there's a world-class surf break every
100 or so yards
we rescue up to a thousand people a year
definitely one of the most dangerous
stretches of beaches in the
world my name is tao hannemann
and i've been a lifeguard for 14 years
here on the north shore
i work here at iokai beach park
it's the home
of the surf break bonsai pipeline which
is a very dangerous wave that breaks in
very shallow water
it's such a critical wave that if you
fall down the chances of getting injured
of hitting the reef is very high
even when it's really small we have very
strong powerful rip currents
it's very easy to get swept out in the
rip current and not be able to make it
back to shore
just yesterday the lifeguards made about
20 rescues
knowing that the possibility of drowning
is very real you know especially in
large surf we all train
my training consists of running the
beach of swimming
anything basically in my area
we do mock rescues if the surf is big
i'll tell one of my partners hey
go go out and get pounded in the surf
i'll come get you with a rescue tube
so he'll go out and like you know he's
taking ways on the head and we'll see
how fast we can get to him
whatever the ocean is going to do if
someone
needs help and you have to go get that
person you got to be ready to to do that
you're putting yourself in a very risky
situation but knowing that your partner
has your back there's it builds a strong
sense of camaraderie
we have a good morale between us all
we do this job for the love of the job
basically if you can save another
person's life
it's very rewarding for sure
[Music]
[Applause]
montana is a landlocked state it blows
my mind every day but there is waves in
the river and you can surf them on
surfboards just like you would in the
ocean we have a huge surf culture here
in missoula
[Music]
my name is kevin benhart brown i go by
kb and i own strong water mountain surf
company
we are the original mountain surf shop
and still the only surf shop in the
state of montana i mean it's cowboy
country here
[Music]
surfing is in my soul one of my very
first earliest memories at the age of
three is visiting my grandparents in san
diego and seeing surfing in the ocean
and for whatever reason i've been kind
of searching for surfing my whole life
and i happen to be here in missoula
montana and tapped into river surfing
in the river
it's a standing wave so the wave is
essentially stationary you're going back
and forth across the wave but the wave
is kind of in one place the water's
coming at you it's pretty amazing
you know we've built a really strong
river surf community here
there's just a ton of support and good
vibes and good energy
this whole connection with nature
correlates directly with kind of that
same vibe that you get in the ocean
not a lot of people know about river
surfing but there's river surfing
communities popping up everywhere and
it's just starting to explode
for me personally it's about doing
what people don't think you can do and
proving that you can do it and
you know just getting out and having a
good time sharing the sport
it's exciting and fun to be on this
whole new frontier